hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play I want to be
the guy guy Dan the original no no no
this is not guy Dan this is the original
not guy Dan so this is a rage game if
you haven't seen me play I want to be
the guy guy Dan you can find it
somewhere on a note probably at the end
of this video but uh I'm not hopped up
on cold medicine but I'm I think you'll
find that my personality doesn't exactly
change when I play these raid games
alright whatever this one new game on
hard why not hello how's it going this
looks good ok so what do we got here is
that it ok and zi2 shoot let's jump
what's jump tell me what jump is I began
to paused
I don't want Ponzi Apple get there what
what's ok
roars restart
I haven't even started the game and I
managed to kill myself q kills yourself
Wow
that's useful what is jump ok shift is
jump ok shoot the same thing good I
saved right when I started I'm not doing
great I should have known
[ __ ] known it was obvious ah oh it
stopped right there ok I'm ok
ah I just remember the nightmare oh this
game is a son of a [ __ ] and I'm gonna
get very upset towards this get out of
here get out there
alright I'll try you back off I try you
back off haha it did the same thing I
expected him to come and never mind you
know uh nominated and whatever alright
then ah come on
ok this is gonna take me for freaking
ever because if everyone is gonna get
that I'm gonna die in all these levels
until I ah go away
thank you what you gonna do you can't do
something different that's right
all plead nude beach are you it's gotta
meet Chuck sees dammit
I'm gonna be here forever try to wait
for God to die of a [ __ ] okay whatever
you know what fine I don't care
I'm gonna get through this and everyone
is gonna be so happy with me I still
don't know how to get through this next
part
maybe I just gotta wait maybe I gotta
wait here let's wait here a moment it's
just all your horses crap what ah
okay come on come on come on
oh my god we're not gonna make it ah
okay bye oh wow what those and rolled ah
nah son of a [ __ ] oh you [ __ ]
[ __ ] so what am I supposed to do here
huh ah I go ah don't have something a
grappling hook why is that one tooth
shaking what do we do
whoa whoa whoa whoa
before there was another one right there
what the hell is going on with this game
he's got to be like oh shut up I'm
getting out of here
really though it's gonna be oh really
I'm gonna assume that would ha but uh
those cherries are apples your apples
aren't they no okay
all right
oh okay come on oh and of our guitar god
dammit I'm gonna I'm gonna load my mind
a mama hood haha
what now brown rubber rubber ha ha ha
yeah oh not gonna get me oh oh oh oh
come on all right
oh no no oh don't wanna play
hey come on about what you guys do to me
doubled no ah yes right mother hopper oh
my god I'm gonna kill someone gonna
strangle a baby oh my god I'm gonna lose
my god frickin mind huh huh Oh God oh
you some monkey huh
oh my god I'm a ha ha ha ha ha whoa Wow
I just son of a [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ]
you're shot of a [ __ ] I got a boy I'm
gonna war Oh mmm I love it I love dying
oh gosh tastes so good mmm
oh the pain is the pain is exquisite mmm
ha ha ha yeah can I shoot that damn what
am I gonna do I don't know how to get
through here I don't know god damn it
mother humping half a day ahh
I can stand on the cloud not that one
though what you were you were doing so
good just maybe I just go over them that
would be the smart technique wouldn't it
whoa hey touch me
this is bull this is all bull it's like
oh mama go go go Oh give me one more get
Oh give it to me yeah that's come on
baby you know I'm good for it a little
bit more come on do it for me do it for
me don't be like that don't be like that
so I get on this cloud then I got up
immediately gone no maybes I just ran
past him it wouldn't be a problem I have
no idea oh my god I'm like king of I'm
gonna get a freaking hernia this is run
before can believable as I'm African
ever of groovin ah
you're not Oh Brava miss na Brava
listen uh Brava Oh God
dance break
oh my god I'm gonna what do i do i I
don't know what to do
ah oh no don't kill a god what good for
me ha ha oh come on don't make me I
wanna I wanna I wanna talk dirty to you
you like that you like when I talk dirty
your luscious apples mmm they're so red
and round
I like their stems they're so tasty
delicious and good for you
oh yeah that's right you're such bad
apples Oh
oh okay what do I do okay oh come on oh
no you did it I'm done you know I'm done
I can't do this anymore I've gotten
worse since I started shut up you stupid
goddamn music okay just shut up shut the
hell up I'm done I'm done with you I'm
done with this game
I can't even get to the first save point
I'm done I can't do it anymore I can't
even get Patsy apples anymore screw this
game okay all right if you want to play
for yourself
ah if you want to play for yourself the
link is in the description below as
always so try it out give it a try cry
for yourself and then we'll see what
happens so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotations for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
Oh
and so bad
which one of these is going to explode
but uh
ah
can I make it up there